[Music]
the european parliament and the european
film academy
celebrate filmmakers bringing european
stories to our screens
and we need you to get involved by
becoming part of europe's biggest film
jury ever
the new lux audience award champions
inspiring films that reflect the beauty
and diversity of european cinema
for the first time the public together
with members of the european parliament
will choose the winner
three films have been nominated the
things in
[Music]
in another round danish filmmaker thomas
winterberg teams up with actor mads
mickelson
four jaded high school teachers try out
a boozy experiment
but it soon goes off the rails
in 2015 a fire in a bucharest nightclub
led to the death of 64 people
collective focuses on journalists whose
investigation into the fire exposes
rampant corruption in the health care
sector
get the book done
[Music]
the blistering moral drama corpus
christi follows daniel
an ex-convict who finds himself filling
in as the local priest in a small
polish town his unconventional methods
help his parishioners
the three films will be subtitled in the
24 official eu languages and screened
across europe until april 2021
the winner will be announced in a
plenary ceremony in the european
parliament
the lux audience award supports the
circulation of european films
enabling thousands of film lovers to see
the very best of european cinema